gençler Merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz Ben
Barış Hoca namı diğer Doktor biyoloji
yeni eğitim öğretim hayatınız Hayırlı
uğurlu olsun umarım bugüne kadar
aldığınız eğitimden çok çok çok daha
kaliteli çok daha heyecanlı ve çok daha
verimli bir eğitim hayatınız olur lisede
9 sınıf Evet çok zor bir sınıftır
öğrencilerimiz dedi ki hocam biz bunları
anlamakta zorlanıyoruz o zaman Ne
yapalım Elbette ki öğrencilerimizin
çağrısına cevap Verelim bu derslerin
hazırlanmasında emeği geçen çok kıymetli
öğretmenlerim var başta Kubilay Kurnaz
Tuncay Tursun Ve tabii ki sizlerin
yaşlarındayken bilimsel makalelerle beni
biyolojiye aşık eden moleküler biyoloji
Tıp biyokimya alanlarında araştırma
yapmama vesile olan kıymetli biyoloji
öğretmenim Hasan İnce'ye huzurlarınızda
teşekkür etmek istiyorum yeni müfredat
yeni öğretim modeli ile karşımıza çıktı
Elbette ki eksik olacak elbette ki
eleştirdiğimiz noktalar olacak ama kol
kırılır yen içinde kalır Demişler biz
bunun gelişmesi için elimizden
geldiğince var gücümüzde Gece gündüz
çalışacağız öğretmenleriniz sizlerin can
yeleği Arkadaşlar lütfen onlara sıkı
sıkı sarılın Öyleyse 4 yıl boyunca
söyleyeceğimiz üzere hadi gelin birlikte
öğrenelim Öğretim modelinin en önemli
avantajlarından bir tanesi Elbette ki
öğrencinin olaya daha çok dahil
edilmesini sağlamaktır Yani daha
interaktif dersler öğrencinin araştırma
yaparak daha çok sunum yaparak bilimsel
çalışmaları yakından takip ederek ya da
onu
anlamlandırır istediğimiz bir model
olarak karşımıza geliyor temelde birinci
konumuz biyolojideki dönüm noktaları ve
bilim insanlarının biyolojiye yaptığı
katkılar olacak biyoloji Elbette ki
birçok evlat doğurmuş bir bilim dalı
genetik tıbbi biyoloji biyokimya
biyoteknoloji Tıp moleküler biyoloji ve
birçok mühendisliğe Aslında el atmış
Doku kültürü yöntemlerine genetik
mühendisliğine Dolayısıyla biyolojinin
tek bir başlık altında incelenmesi
Elbette ki mümkün değil kaldı ki her bir
canlıyı sistematik kategorileri
içerisinde ayrı ayrı inceleyen bir sürü
bilim dalı var mesela fungiler inceleyen
yani mant ları inceleyen mikoloji
mikroorganizmaları inceleyen
mikrobiyoloji canlılığı ya da cansızlığı
tartışılan virüsleri inceleyen viroloji
gibi aslında bir sürü alt başlıkları var
Ve tabii son gündemler imiz bir tanesi
olan kıymetli hocamız Alper Gezer
Avcı'nın yaptığı uzay yolculuğundan
sonra birtakım bilim dalları da göz
önüne gelmeye başladı İşte bunların en
önemlisi uzay biyoloji ile ilgilenen
astrobiyoloji kavramları vesaire gibi
şimdi bir takım bir takım kavramlar
göreceksiniz o kavramlardan bazıları
Elbette ki genel kültür tadında olacak
mesela ilk konu bu videonun konusu
Aslında ösym'yi çok ilgilendiren bir
konu değil ancak biyolojiye giriş
maksadıyla yazılmış bir konu arkadaşlar
işte bilimsel çalışmaların biyolojideki
önemi ve bilim insanları ne var mesela
burada bir örnek var moki denilen bir
cihaz var bu cihazla oksijen üretmeye
çalışıyor bilim insanları ve
bitkilerdeki Aslında fotolizi taklit
ediyor fotolizi fotos tezde size
öğreteceğim suyun elektron hidrojen ve
oksijenin ayrılması olayıdır ışığın
etkisiyle burada suyun içerisindeki
oksijen atmosferin serbest oksijeni
haline geliyor mokin yaptığı şey
karbondioksitten oksijen elde etmek
Burada tabii açığa yan ürün olarak
karbonmonoksit çıkabiliyor
karbonmonoksit insan için inanılmaz
derecede zehirli bir gaz O yüzden
Bununla ilgili de elbette ki çalışmalar
devam ediyor insanların ayın ötesine
seyahat etmesine katkı sağlayacak
biyolojik araç tırmalar hangi alanlarda
yapılabilir dendiğinde benim aklıma
Aslında hibernasyon uyku teknolojisi ve
soğukta saklama kö rezervasyon geliyor
kop prezervasyon biraz daha farklı bir
yöntem Elbette ki hani uzay yolculuğuna
çıkacak bilim insanlarına uygulanır mı
soru işareti Ama derin uykuda metabolik
faaliyetlerin minimum seviyeye
indirilerek kişinin beslenme ihtiyacını
da ortadan kaldırdığımızda uyku halinde
yıllarca seyahat etmesini sağlayacak
birtakım teknolojiler üzerinde
çalışıldığını biliyoruz kryo
prezervasyon biraz daha farklı bir
yöntem burada dondurma olayı var elbette
ki bu dondurma olayında mantık şu
yaşlanmış bireyler ya da bir hastalığa
sahip olan bireyler teknoloji Eğer
gelişirse ve yaşlanmayı ya da o
hastalıkları ortadan kaldıracak
teknikler Eğer elde edilirse bu
insanları tekrar uyandırmayı
amaçlamaktadır moksi hangi canlılardan
veya biyolojik süreçlerden esinlenerek
geliştirilmiş bitkilerde ya da
fotosentez yapan mikroorganizmalarda
suyu kullanan suyu kullandığı sırada da
oksijen açığa çıkartan
mikroorganizmalardan esinlenerek
yapılmış biyoloji biliminin
ilişkilendirilebilecek diğer bilim
dalları hangileri olabilir dendiğinde
Tabii ki Dediğim gibi dersin başında
biyoloji çok fazla evlada sahip ama
elbette ki yan kollardan da yararlanıyor
mühendislikten Kimyadan Fizikten
yararlanıyor mesela tıptaki görüntüleme
cihazlarına baktığınız zaman işte
tomografi gibi MR gibi Elbette ki
fizikteki gelişmelerden yararlanmış
oluyoruz ya da işte tahlil
laboratuvarlarında kullandığımız
kimyasal maddeleri göz önünde
bulundurduğumuzda biyokimyadan Kimyadan
yararlanmış oluyoruz biyoloji bilimi Son
yıllarda çok revaçta olmaya başladı Evet
bazı şeylerin kıymeti sonradan anlaşılır
biyoloji de öyle bir bilim dalı hocam
Normal şartlar altında genetikte
biyokimyada fizyolojide bu tarz bilim
dallarında oluşan gelişmeler insanları
Evet heyecanlandırıyor ve son zamanlarda
çok fazla biyoloji Temelli işte
fizyolojide biyokimyada Nobel ödülleri
verilmeye başlandı özellikle Aziz
Hoca'dan beri Aziz sancar'dan beri
gözümüzün önünde bu Nobel ödülleri Orada
işte yine DNA tamir mekanizması ile
alakalı bir sistem vardı Nobel ödülü
kazandırmıştı Burada da crisper
teknolojisi yani yeni crisper C 9
teknolojisi DNA Temelli hasarları
onarabilen takip edeceğimiz teknoloji
sizinle de sohbet edeceğimiz Teknoloji
bu olacak biyoloji alanındaki önemli
buluşların insan hayatına katkıları
nedir şimdi g iği tıbbı moleküler
biyolojiyi düşündüğünüz zaman Elbette ki
insan hayatını kolaylaştıran
hastalıkların tedavi edilmesini sağlayan
ömrü uzatan birtakım çalışmalar olduğunu
görüyoruz işte bunları da Heyecanla
bekliyoruz biyoloji canlıların
yapılarını ve işlevlerini inceleyen ve
yaşamın doğasını anlamaya çalışan bilim
dalı yaşamın doğasından kastımız Tabii
ki hep insan özelinde konuşuyoruz ama
aslında dünyayı bir bütün olarak
ekosistem lerin tamamını bir bütün
olarak düşündüğümüz zaman biyoloji
bunların hepsiyle ilgilenir ve en
önemlisi
sürdürülebilen sürdürülebilirlik
kavramının çok fazla tanımı var ama
benim sizden ricam şu gelecek nesilleri
düşünerek var olan kaynakları verimli
bir şekilde kullanmaktır
sürdürülebilirlik Bu benim için en
kıymetli tanımlardan bir tanesi Çünkü
biz sadece kendi yaşadığımız zaman
dilimini değil Yıllar Sonra
torunlarımızın onların çocuklarını
düşünecek şekilde hareket
etmeliyiz biyoloji bilimindeki dönüm
noktalarından bahsedeceğimiz zaman ilk
örneklerden bir tanesi Elbette ki
Alexander fleming'in bulduğu keşfettiği
penisilin Biz öğretmenlerimizle
karşılıklı yorum yaparken toplantıda
helikobakter piloriden de bahsetmek
istedik Çünkü aslında bilimde birçok
şeyin rastlantı sonucu oluştuğunu
biliyoruz mesela onlardan bir tanesi
helikobakter pilorinin keşfedilmesi
şimdi ana konumuza dönelim Alexander
Fleming le mikrobiyoloji derslerinde
anlatılan bir anekdot vardır O da şu
Alexander Fleming Aslında pasaklı bir
adam yani bilimsel çalışma yaptığı
sırada çalışma yaptığı alanda yemek
yiyebilen sağa sola ekmek kırıntıları
dökebilir kişi ve bir gün Laboratuvardan
Uzunca bir süre ayrılıyor sonra geri
dönüyor arkadaşıyla yaptığı sohbet
sırasında bir şey dikkatini çekiyor
Tabii burada işte size şunu söylemek
istiyorum bakmakla görmek arasında bir
fark var herkes bakar bilim insanı görür
Alexander Fleming kültür kaplarının
içerisinde küf mantarını görüyor Ve küf
mantarını görmekle kalmıyor aynı zamanda
küf mantarın etrafında bakteri
kolonilerinin çoğal amadı fark ediyor
demek ki bakterileri rahatsız eden bir
materyal vardır sonucuna varıyor İşte o
materyal bu küf mantarının salgıladığı
kimyasal madde bu küf mantarın özel adı
penisilyum notatum mantarın salgıladığı
madde dünyanın en güçlü Antibiyotikler
inden bir tanes olan penisilin
antibiyotiği ve bir rivayete göre
Aslında Dünya Savaşı sırasında
keşfedilen bu materyal milyonlarca
insanın ölümünü de engellemiş Çünkü
neden askerler Normal şartlarda sadece
kurşunla ölmüyor enfeksiyonla da
ölüyorlar Dolayısıyla enfeksiyondan
korunmalarını sağlayan bir yöntem
Elbette Alexander Fleming bunu tek
başına yapmıyor Çünkü Fleming
penisilinin varlığını keşfediyor ancak
penisilini çok miktarda üretebileceği
saf bir şekilde üretebileceği bir
tekniği ya da bir bütçesi yok işte o
dönem de oxford'da bilim insanları
florey ve chain bu problemin üstesinden
gelebilmek için Amerika'ya doğru yola
çıkıyorlar ve gerekli ekonomik
faktörleri de sağladıktan sonra çok
miktarda penisilin üretilmeye başlanıyor
İşte bu bilim insanları Alexander
Fleming florey ve chain Nobel ödülüyle
ödüllendiriliyor bize bazı Bilim
insanlarından bahsedilmiş mesela
Akşemsettin onlardan bir tanesi ancak
Burada birazcık bilimsel hatalar var
nedir bilimsel hata Akşemsettin
Mikroorganizma vesaire dememiş Çünkü
Mikroorganizma diye bir şey bilmiyor Bir
kere Mikroorganizma mikroskobun keşfiyle
ortaya çıkan bir şey bakın ikinci
maddede mikroskobun keşfi 1665 li
yıllara dayanırken Akşemsettin 1459 da
vefat ediyor Yani bunu okuldaki
öğretmeninizle zaten çok rahat bir
şekilde tartışabilirsiniz Ayrıca burada
mikroorganizmadan çok gözle görülemeyen
faktörlerden bahsettiğini biliyoruz ama
ilk kişi yine değ il çünkü ondan önce
yaşayan İbn Sina var İbn Sina hakikaten
cerrahi aletlerini ateşten geçirdiği
söyleniyor mikrobiyoloji derslerinde
Yine bize enfeksiyon hastalıklarıyla
alakalı dersler anlatıldığı sırada bu
vurgu çok yapılır ateşten geçirme işlemi
tamamen Aslında gözle görünmeyen
birtakım varlıkların yok edilmesi ile
ilişkilendiriliyor Tabii tartışma konusu
Bunlar düzeltilir mi düzeltilir
mikroskobun keşfi Robert Hook onun
sayesinde artık gözle göremediğimiz
mikroorganizmalardan bahsetmeye
başlıyoruz schleiden shivan ve virsh
özellikle hücrelerle alakalı çalışmış ve
hücre teorisinin oluşturulmasına çok
ciddi katkılarda bulunmuş kalıtım Gregor
Mendel yaptığı çalışmalarla bazı
faktörlerin çocuklara yavrulara Ata
bireylerden aktarıldığını söylüyor ve
bizim de birtakım özelliklerin anneden
babadan çocuklara nasıl geçtiğini
anlamamız için bir yol açıyor Az önce
bahsettik aler Fleming penisilinin keşfi
ile ilgili çalışmalar yapıyor rosalin
Franklin James Watson ve Francis creek
James Watson ve Francis creek Benim
sevmediğim iki bilim insanı tartışılır
Tabii ki Elbette ki bilime katkıları
vardır bilime katkılarından dolayı saygı
duyuyorum ancak burada rosalin
Franklin'in yana tavrımı koyuyorum Çünkü
rosalin Franklin x ışınlarını kullanarak
DNA'nın ü boyutlu yapısını
modelleyen esinlenen diğer diğer iki
bilim insanı Nobel ödülünü almışlar
Tabii rosalin Franklin x ışınlarından
etkilendiği için erken yaşta vefat
ediyor ve vefat edene Nobel ödülü
verilmiyor biliyorsunuz rekombinant DNA
teknolojisi recombination tekrar kombine
etmek aslında bir DNA'ya sahip olmadığı
bir özelliği aktarmak bu tarz bir
gelişme çok ama çok kıymetli Çünkü DNA
Temelli değişiklikler yapılacağı zaman
biz restriksiyon endonükleaz enzimlerini
kullanıyoruz birazdan bundan
bahsedeceğim ve polimeraz zincir
reaksiyonu PCR çok duydunuz özellikle
Korona döneminde PCR PCR Neydi bu PCR
Aslında temel mantıkta laboratuvar
ortamında küçük ependorf tüpleri
ependorf tüpü yazarsanız internete
göreceksiniz ependorf tüpleri içerisinde
DNA'nın küçük bir cihazda çoğaltılması
çok basit bir mantığı var önce yüksek
sıcaklığa 90 derecelik sıcaklıklara
çıkartılıyor DNA DNA parçası iki zinciri
birbirinden ayrılıyor sonra tüpün
içerisine daha önceden koyulmuş olan
primerler DNA parçaları DNA'ların
ayrılan zincirlerine yapışıyor Bu da
belli bir sıcaklık değerinde oluyor Daha
sonra tak polimeraz dediğimiz termus
aquaticus bakterisinden izole edilmiş
olan enzimle arkadaşlar DNA sentezi
başlıyor bir cihazın içerisinde ve bu
PCR mantığı ne işe yarar ki
biyoteknolojide de öğreneceksiniz bunu
pcr'da aslında Kısa zamanda çok sayıda
DNA materyali üretmek var Canlı
klonlaması dün gibi hatırlıyorum orta
okuldaydım 1996 yılında wilmut ön plana
o çıkıyordu genelde işte Dolly klonlamış
tı klonlama Hocam şu anda artık son
aşamalarına neredeyse gelmiş durumda Ama
Elbette ki insan üzerinde yapılan
çalışmalar biraz kısıtlamaya
karşılaştığı için biz birçoğundan
haberdar edilmiyor Çünkü biz biliyoruz
ki primatlar yani maymunlar orangutanlar
şempanzeler vesaire oraya bak baktığımız
zaman oradaki canlıların klonlandığını
duyduk onlar klonlanabilir de % 19698
oranda benzerlik gösteren Canlar Demek
ki bir yerlerde acaba Bunun yorumunu
size bırakıyorum İnsan Genom Projesi
başladığı zaman Aslında 20 yıl 30 yıl
sürebilir dendi çünkü o dönemde insanın
100.000 tane 100 binden fazla gene sahip
olduğu düşünülüyordu ama bakıldı ki
insanda 18.000 tane gen var ve
planlanandan çok daha önce biten bir
çalışma İnsan Genom Projesi yine ben
lisedeydim 2000 yılında Times dergisinde
inanılmaz bir gündem yapılmıştı işte
Times kapağında bu vardı o dönemlerde de
onu okuyorduk biz inşallah Siz daha
güzel daha heyecan verici şeyler
okuyacaksınız işte onlardan bir tanesi
crisper kas sistemi nedir hocam crisper
kas sistemi dna'yı farklı gen
bölgelerinden aynı anda kesebileceği
muhteşem bir yöntem crisper neden dna'yı
kesiyoruz ki hocam genetik Temelli Bir
problem varsa genetik bir hastalık varsa
sorunlu bir gen varsa eksik bir gen
varsa yerine koyabilmek ya da
değiştirebilmek adına bunu yapabiliyoruz
şimdi Elbette yeni nesil aşıların
geliştirilmesi ile alakalı da
konuşacağım ama RNA Temelli çalışmalar
Aslında biraz daha eski yani böyle
bakmayın son zamanlarda covid ile
gündeme gelen bir mrna aşısı mantığı var
ama mrna aşısının mantığı şudur Siz bir
hücrenin içerisine o mrna verdiğiniz
zaman mrna'nın üzerindeki
kodun hangi proteinle ilişkili isse onun
sentezlenmesini sağlıyorsunuz ve bu
protein arkadaşlar virüsle alakalı bir
protein olduğu için bu protein
üretildiğinde vücut bu proteini tanıyor
ve buna karşı antikorlar geliştiriyor
buna karşı makrofajlar nötrofiller Yani
bizim vücudumuzdaki fagositoz yapıp
ortadan problemi kaldıracak olan
hücrelerin uyarılması sağlanıyor mrna
çalışmaları dediğim gibi çok eskiye
dayanıyor Ama şimdi çok da
detaylandırmak yok şimdi biyoloji
alanında dönüm noktası olarak görülen
keşiflerden ben özellikle rekombinant
DNA teknolojisinden polimeraz zincir
reaksiyondan crisper K9 sisteminden ve
mrna aşılarının geliştirilmesinden temel
olarak tekrar bahsedeceğim size Ama önce
crisper K9 sistemi ki beni
heyecanlandıran sistem Tabii bu sisteme
geçmeden önce şunu hemen belirteyim
Elbette ki hep hepiniz Hekim hepiniz
moleküler biyolog ya da farmakolog
olmayacaksınız Elbette ki bunun
farkındayım ama aranızda mühendis olacak
arkadaşlar için de bir uyarıda bulunmak
istiyorum uyarı yapmak istiyorum
arkadaşlar hayatınızın bir dönemi
mutlaka biyolojiyle kesişecek yani
elektronik mühendis de olsanız
bilgisayar mühendis de olsanız yazılımcı
da olsanız biyotek biyoteknolojinin
herhangi bir alanıyla mutlaka mutlaka
bir gün karşılaşacaksınız bunu da Barış
hocanız size söylemiş olsun Çünkü yapay
doku yapay organ genetik Temelli
çalışmalardaki cihazlar ve bunların
geliştirilmesi mutlaka mutlaka sizin
gözünüzün önünde olacak Lütfen kendinizi
bunlardan
soyutlamaya
kendisine rehber olarak kullanan bir
enzim düşünün Aslında bu sistem
virüslerden bakterilerin kendilerini
korumak için yarattıkları doğal bir
sistem ve bu doğal sistemi Biz aslında
taklit ed nasıl taklit edeceğiz şimdi
bir virüs DNA'sı bakterinin içerisine
girdiği zaman o bakteri hemen o virüs
dna'sını fark ediyor ve virüs dna'sının
parçalanmasını sağlıyor İşte biz bunu
kopyalayıcı o
rna'ların kendisini yönlendirmesini
sağlıyoruz buraya koyduğumuz RNA İşte o
üzerinde sıkıntılı bölge olan dna'yı
buluyor Ve orayı tamir ediyor kesiyor
yerine başka bir genin başka başka bir
DNA parçasının koyulması sağlıyor neden
üstün bir çalışma bu çünkü hocam birden
fazla gene etki edebiliyor aynı süre
içerisinde bu da multifaktöriyel
hastalıkların tedavisi için çok ama çok
önemli bir Atılım DNA üzerinde
değişiklik yapılan çalışmalar ne bilmek
istiyorum bunun insan ömrüne ve genetik
yapısına katkısı nedir peki Hocam bize
bu çalışmaları anlatırken neyden
faydalandım bilimsel makaleden
faydalandım bilimsel makale güvenilir mi
Evet çünkü bizzat çalışmayı yapan
Jennifer and duna tarafından yazılmış
kaleme alınmış bir makaleyi o makalenin
doi numarasını size vereceğim isteyen
onu bir üniversiteden indirebilir hocam
doi numarasında şu anda öğrenmiş olduğun
makalelerin kimlik numarasıdır bir
makalenin kimlik numarasını girdiğinizde
ona ulaşabilirsiniz ve izniniz varsa
indirebilirsiniz ben o makalenin
kendisini Paylaşamam Çünkü paylaşım izni
yok ancak bir üniversiteden çok rahat
bir şekilde indirilebilir neden
üniversite Çünkü üniversiteler bunları
indirebilmek için bir bütçe ayırıyor
Tabii hocam edu ve Go uzantılı Bir web
sitesi mi Evet ncbi National Center for
bioteknologi işte böyle bir kurum var
Amerika'da bu Amerika'daki kurumun
arkadaşlar sitesiyle bağlantılı
makalelere ulaşabilirsiniz Ne öğrendim
konusunu bir tartışalım sizinle Aslında
DNA üzerinde birtakım değişiklikler
yapabilecek bir çalışmadan bahsediyoruz
istenmeyen bölgelerde ya da eksik
bölgelerde tamir mekanizmasına
gidilebilir insan üzerinde çalışmalar
yapılmış mı Evet yapılmış yapılmaya da
devam ediyor birçoğu izinli ancak Tabii
ki izinsiz çalışmalarda var hatta
gündeme gelen 34 yıl önce gündeme gelen
Çin'de bir çalışma vardı henüz doğmamış
ikiz bebekler üzerinde birtakım genetik
çalışmalar yapan bilim insanının
arkadaşlar diplomasına el konuluyor ve
kendisi hapis cezasıyla yargılanıyor
ancak Victoria Grey adlı bir kadının
orak hücre anemisinin tedavisinde Bu
yöntem kullanılmakta şu anda arkadaşlar
onunla ilgili de sonuçlara Haberlere
ulaşabilirsiniz Victoria Grey Onun da
ismini aşağıda açıklamalara bırakacağım
bilime çok fazla katkıda bulunan kadın
var Özellikle moleküler biyolojide kadın
ismi çok fazla geçecek ve size şunu da
söyleyebilirim 2008 yılında
amerika'dayım Hil henrietta lex adlı
Rahim kanserinden öldüğü saptanan
kadının hücreleri kanserli hücreleri
neredeyse şu anda bütün moleküler
biyoloji laboratuvarlarında mevcut ve o
hücreler üzerinde hala çalışmalar
yapılmakta hocam diğer bir çalışma
rekombinant DNA teknolojisi
recombination tekrar kombine etmek dedim
bu ne demek bakın çok basit bir şekilde
size anlatacağım diyelim ki Elinizde bir
DNA var ve bu DNA'nın Şöyle mesela
insülin kodlayan bir gen bölge var İşte
o insülin kodlayan gen bölgesini bir
bakteri dna'sına aktarabilirsiniz nasıl
yapacaksınız restriksiyon enzimleri
denilen restriction kesme dna'yı belli
noktalardan kesen enzimler var Bunlar da
yine bakterilerden izole edilmiş
enzimler ki barış hocanız zamanında Eko
R1 ile çalışıyordu nd1
xh1 şeklinde bir sürü arkadaşlar enzim
var dna'yı belli dizilerden kesen Siz bu
rest endonükleaz enzimiyle hem
bakterinin dna'sını kesebilir hem de
buradan bu geni çıkarabilirsiniz Şimdi
ben bunu buradan çıkarttım diyelim Bu
insülin kodlayan gen bakteriyi de şu
şekilde kestim ve yapışık uç oluşturdum
işte Daha sonra ligaz denilen bir enzim
yani bağlayan birleştiren anlamına gelir
bir enzimle bu iki DNA parçasını şöyle
beyaz yapalım bunu bu ik DNA parçasını
birleştirirsek hocam ligaz enzimiyle
birleştirdim diyelim Ne olacak şimdi
artık benim bir rekombinant tekrar
kombine edilmiş DNA var hiç sahip
olmadığı bir özelliğe sahip ve gideceğim
ben şimdi bunu bir bakteriye aktaracağım
bakteriye aktarınca ne olacak hocam
bakteri kendini çoğaltırken İşte benim
koyduğum bu rekombinant dna'yı da
çoğaltmıştır
sonra ben özel yöntemlerle ki sonikasyon
sesle parçalama yöntemi kullanıyordum Bu
sesle parçalanan duvarlardan insülin
alınacak
saflaştırılmış anda pcr'da bahsettik
polymerase chain reaction yani
zincirleme arka arkaya polimeraz enzim
reaksiyonları elinizdeki DNA'nın
ependorf tüpü içerisinde dakikalar
içinde çok fazla kopyasının
çıkarılmasını sağlayan bir cihaz
arkadaşlar burada da tak polimeraz
denilen bir enzim kullanılıyor ki sıcağa
dayanıklı bir enzim termus aquaticus
denilen bakteriden izole edilmiş İşte
bunlar arkadaşlar sizin biyolojiye Aşık
olmanızı sağlayacak temel faktörler
lütfen biyolojiyi işte ezber dersidir
okuruz geçeriz sınavlarda bir şekilde
yaparız tarzını düşünmeyin hakikaten
sizi anlatan Çevrenizi anlatan
sevdiğiniz canlıları anlatan ve doğayı
anlamanızı sağlayan bir bilim dalından
bahsediyoruz bu kadar kıymetli bir bilim
dalından bahsediyoruz Elbette ki hepsi
çok çok çok önemli ama lütfen biyolojiye
bu gözle bakın sadece iki tane organel
ezberlediğiniz iki tane bilim insanı
ezberlediğiniz bir ders değildir
biyoloji son olarak bu videonun sonunda
diğer videoya geçmeden önce burada bir
tane bulmaca var sizler için çözdüm
zaten pdf'i aşağıya ekledim arkadaşlar
dileyen buradan cevaplarına bakar üstte
konuştuğumuz her şeyi soru haline
getirip bir bulmaca yapmışlar ve anahtar
kelime olarak şifre olarak da bilim
kelimesi çıkmış Evet burada bir mola
verelim ikinci videoda artık bilimsel
çalışmalardan bahsedelim
[Müzik]